you like it britney spears is engaged to
samasari the couple have been dating
since 2016. well trust me if we do ever
get married everybody's gonna know
actually you might be the first one to
know you never know the pop star shared
the big news to instagram on sunday
look at that
you like it
brainy kept it short and sweet in the
caption writing i can't believe it and
e.t has learned this engagement has been
in the works for some time now is she
the one do you see marriage in the
future i mean absolutely this is
something that every couple should do
that's the whole point of a relationship
we're a family before popping the
question with this four carat diamond
ring sam had been quietly meeting with
designers for months eventually choosing
roman malliev to design the stunning
rock a rep for sam said in a statement
that the couple is deeply touched by the
support dedication and love expressed to
them i can't tell you anything yet in a
cute moment sam teased the announcement
in his instagram story writing biggest
news can't wait to share amid her
ongoing legal battle to have her father
jamie removed as her conservator
brittany has praised sam on social media
for being in her corner just last month
bridge shared this adorable couple pick
and wrote not only has this cute apple
been with me through both the hardest
and the best years of my life but he
happens to be an extremely good cook
[Music]
brittany and sam began dating after they
met on the set of her music video
slumber party so what was it like when
you got the gig of a lifetime really and
you got the call you're gonna be
britney's love interest in this video
britney spears the
princess of pop is calling me wanting me
to be the play the love interest of the
movie uh i said why not let me give it a
shot sam opened up to et in 2019 about
their relationship journey we talked on
the music video we talked about what
what do you like to eat sushi here and
there and then you know text messages
and next thing you know they just like a
normal couple i love the most about my
relationship is the fact that it's it's
so normal you know it's not anything
glad like you said it's not glamorous or
anything she inspires me in my work and
also i can give so much to her by going
to the gym by by going to work by having
an actual uh balanced life you know we
can get uh inspired by each other here
and there and really grow with each
other she loves you know dancing working
out and really putting a cute content
she's been an artist forever so the
funny thing is she's been doing this
more than i have you know my my life is
fitness my lifestyle fitness but so is
hers she's always been a dancer she's
always been
an artist and she's always been dancing
and working out and doing all this so
the funny thing is she inspires me when
it comes to that if she with her busy
schedule with her with all of her fame
could do that i can do that no problem
[Music]
you